Also, obwohl ich für Vinick vanna vazhi von z anga ein
Tipp bin, ist wie mein Einsatz in Toronto in
Kanada, kann die Waffe
einen Spaziergang auf der Erde sehen
junge
ste durch fotografie ja auch
eigentlich ich diese gitarre musik mutter und kinder
bei heilmittel hi hi oh hi Johnny aria ja ich
spüre wie die dinge laufen sehr
gut ja ja wir haben viel spaß
wir bekommen eine chance  zu zweit der
welt was wir immer machen wollten und
wir hätten 0 beschwerden ok du hattest dein
leben hat sich seit einigen wochen oder
monaten verändert ja ich habe mich in den letzten
paar monaten verändert davon konnte mich
auf musik konzentrieren a  viel mehr als
vorher, bevor viele von
uns zwei Jobs und Musik
gleichzeitig machen mussten und jetzt können wir uns nur
auf die Musik konzentrieren, was sehr viel Spaß
macht  Ich muss keine Toilette mehr verkaufen,
obwohl es ein sehr
elegantes Geschäft war, ja  Okay Okay und dein
Geschäft ist eigentlich immer in der Schule für Musik,
also ist das so etwas wie die
Erfahrung in der realen Welt. Okay, es ist eine gute
Abwechslung. Gut. Okay und dein Job. Musik
Bett einen Moment,
aber versuch es noch einmal. Ich
bin mit Hunden spazieren gegangen. Welcher Hundeausführer, du warst ein
Doc. Willkommen, du weißt, ich mache es immer noch. Ich
liebe es
kleiner Hund, aber du
hast überhaupt keine Zeit, nein, aber du weißt,
ich kann etwas Zeit damit verbringen, wenn ich nach Hause komme,
okay, ja, ich, ein paar Streuner,
okay, du findest ein paar streunende Hunde und
irgendwie, ja, er muss eine Freilassung bekommen
, weißt du  Also finden wir ein paar streunende Hunde und
gehen los Ja, ich kann damit spazieren gehen, aber es ist ein
Junge, der Hund des Allmächtigen, klein, es ist ein sehr
kleiner, er braucht jeden Tag 500 Meter zu
Fuß, das ist großartig, ich werde dir den
halben Preis berechnen, okay, also, was denkst du?
über Ihre Situation jetzt w  Das ist der
Unterschied, was sich in den letzten Wochen geändert hat
, ähm, wir alle können
jetzt jede Sekunde des Tages viel mehr
zusammen abhängen, und ja, ja, ich weiß nicht,
wir können uns auf Musik konzentrieren, die cool ist,
denn das ist alles, was wir sind  wollte
ich schon immer mal machen, das ist äh, das ist in Ordnung, wie ist es
möglich, einen so schnellen Kurier zu pflanzen,
es ist gut, es ist nicht schnell, weil Sie
sehr früh anfangen wollen, aber das ganze Leben lang
, um es zu tun, und dann, aber jetzt ist es sehr
schnell, ja, jetzt ist es sehr  schnell und ja,
du kannst nicht wirklich Ich war wieder die Frage
, wie es möglich ist, eine
so schnelle Karriere zu planen oder so, ja, in so einem
Moment musst du einfach
bereit sein und es ist offensichtlich, dass es eine
Menge Timing ist  und und Glück, aber es wird auch
so gelesen,
als würde man auf so etwas
hinarbeiten und darauf vorbereitet sein, und sobald es passiert ist, haben wir
uns an die Arbeit gemacht und ein Team an Bord geholt
und Dinge getan, die wir tun mussten, um die
Entscheidungen so kurz zu treffen  schnelle
Zeit Ich denke, wir haben es gut gemacht a
Und wir machen das jetzt weiter und versuchen
sicherzustellen, dass es für eine
lange Zeit mit dem Internet bleibt, jetzt weißt du,
dass es dieses Internet-Ding gibt, das
ziemlich groß wird, und du weißt, dass
du die ganze Welt sehen kannst, die du bekommen kannst
Holen Sie sich die ganze Welt innerhalb von Minuten an Bord
, wissen Sie, also ja, ich denke, wir
glauben jetzt, ja, also werden Sie diesen Erfolg pflanzen,
ähm ja,
ja, wir haben wir, ich meine, wir haben
unser ganzes Leben darauf hingearbeitet und schließlich haben
wir gearbeitet.  Wir sind ziemlich begeistert davon,
wir sind dankbar, aber ja, wir haben es definitiv
geplant, deine Freunde und Familien,
was sagen sie jetzt, sie haben
etwas zu erzählen,
sie sind hübsch, sie sind ziemlich langsame
Leute, also haben sie jetzt etwas zu
reden  über ihr aufgeregtes Kanada, es
heißt Todas, oh, entschuldigen Sie, es heißt
Todo, also singen Sie einfach auf Kanadisch, es
bedeutet, wie gesagt, ja, okay, hey Joe, auf
viele Arten, hey, das habe ich zu meinen Eltern gesagt,
als das passierte, also ja, ich
habe es uns gesagt, also haben Sie es getan  großartiges Jobdesign
c  Sei da, Tony, wenn ich es bewege,
bringt es den Ton durcheinander, also ja, ich muss
es ruhig halten, nein, es ist okay, also, was sind
deine Pläne, deine nächsten Pläne, hast du einen
Plan, ja, oh, das ist die Kindheit als Ziel, das
du erreicht hast, und  Jetzt ist es ja, wir haben einen
Plan für Ihre Schüler, dieses Zeug,
sobald das alles passiert ist, haben wir es geschafft, wie
Johnny vorhin gesagt hat, wir haben ein großartiges Team
an Bord und jetzt, wo wir auch aus
Kolumbien sind, haben wir einen Plan, der im
Grunde so ist  die beste Album-Tour aller Zeiten
hinter diesem Album aufzunehmen und es dann noch
einmal zu machen und es einfach immer und immer wieder zu tun und den
ganzen Kontakt
mit unseren Fans über soziale Medien,
Facebook, YouTube, all das zu
halten, all das Zeug weiter zu machen, also sind wir wirklich hart
Arbeiter und wir werden einfach weiter
Arsch treten Du hast den Erfolg mit
Coversongs dein nächstes Album wird
nur Coversongs enthalten nein das ist eine
Frage nein ich werde nicht wir werden ein
paar Originale haben und dann vielleicht  Ein
paar Cover ja okay ja wir werden nicht
ge  Nicht weg von den Covers, weil wir
nicht so sind, als wollten wir keine weitere Coverband, nun,
wir stimmen nicht mit den Leuten überein, die sagen:
Oh, wir haben gerade ein
paar Cover gemacht, um die Leute dazu zu bringen,
unsere Musik jetzt zu hören  Wir werden nie wieder Coverversionen
machen, wie wir es tun
, weil wir diesen Song mögen
und wir alle Musik lieben, also nehmen wir diesen
Song und ändern ihn so, dass er von der
Erde geht, und dann haben wir immer noch das Gefühl,
dass das unser Song ist, meine ich  Sie haben
die sensiblen 60er wie Bob Dylan
Jimi Hendrix gespielt, sie werden denselben Song spielen,
also werden wir das weiterhin tun,
aber wir haben auch viel Vertrauen in
unsere
Originalmusik, und Sie wissen, wir haben
sechs sieben  Jahre hinter uns in unserer
Originalmusik und viele Leute fühlen sich davon
wirklich angezogen, also werden wir
wirklich mit dem Original
Walk off the Earth im Einklang bleiben und dann auch ein paar
Cover hineinwerfen, okay, also
werde ich hiermit ein zeigen  toller
erfolg danke vielen dank ein paar griffe auspacken
bin kein jüde ich bin  aveda a YouTube
stassney sogar Aspirinbomben, in denen
jemand Geldjunge, der Dean, eine
Taps-Liga und einen Geruch und eine erweiterte
Kontrolle genießen kann